[Music]
get that one that's a great read there
and that's kind of old school basketball
is having a rim run there by Davis for
them really for Anthony Davis was a
point guard oh goodness
and there you go that's why you don't
run plays when you can just throw it up
at the rim and let a beam go get it
being able to come out and start
that's impressive I know you had a
chance continue this is why I like this
that come up a hard curl big big fella
rolls it
just keep battling on the offensive
glass and it's Davis both teams are
being super bad don't run in to break
their kid easy looks especially the
Pelican Steve they're sure you know I
watched Rondo's Isaac rafting when you
looked at it you don't think he can play
but but he does a great job would change
the speed to get in there and make it
easy shot sure I mean he makes that shot
with a lot of regularity started in the
third quarter just because of his energy
try to give the Clippers back in this
game
he's gonna get the end one on that shot
now is this an n1 the lackluster effort
and that's the little you have the
dockworkers yes not a pregame when they
go with this line I'm Luis DeAndre
Jordan's are about Kevin
you see DeAndre Jordan right there got a
help out on Mira chick right there it
was a mismatch down down just Ben Davis
Davis T threes already in this quarter
exactly so far off you can't even can
test the shuttles I've gotta get a
little bit knocks down that supplement
graphic we just had up there brief LOC
maybe 2062 quote there yeah you can't
get it at point-blank they're just way
too long
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
top baby like you know that Anthony's
lady keep decision drive right pass or
shoot quickly really hard shot for a guy
seven feet that's hard for ya yeah
that's their favorite story
to go to right here in Greece for New
York City
and a foul as well as that all of a
sudden that bonded offense
elegans has become stagnant until
they've disabled to get that piece but
it's a two-point week double team summer
should be wide open
[Applause]
or gets it back too
the acrobatic fall away Thanks I want to
get you shot
[Applause]
almost giving up that opportunity
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Anthony Davis put a shade away on them